ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد اتهم وزير
الدفاع الهندي ركنه الصين بمحاوله تغيير
الوضع القائم بشكل احادي عند الحدود
المتنازع عليها بين الطرفين في الهيمالايا
عندما اسفرت اشتباكات الاسبوع الماضي عن
سقوط جرحى من الجانبين واقل وزير الهندي
التاسع من ديسمبر حاولت قوه جيش التحرير
الشعبي الصيني تغيير الوضع القائم بشكل
احادي عبر التعدي على خط السيطره الفعليه
في منطقه
ولفت سينغ الى ان المواجهه التي اعاقبت
منورات العسكريه امريكيه هنديه مشتركه قرب
الحدود اثارت غضبه بكين وادت الى اصابات
في صفوف الصمود من الجانبين في المقابل
اكدت الصين انا الوضع مستقر عند حدودها مع
الهندسه واوضح الناطق باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه بان الطرفين حافظا على حوار من
دون عقيل بشان المس الحدوديه عبر القنوات
الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا صحفي
نادرونج اهلا بيكم من نيودلهي وصحفي
سانجاي كومار اهلا بكمين واسمح لي انا
بكين معك سيد نادر في الواقع المناوشات
الحدوديه الصينيه الهنديه ليست بالامر
الجديد بين الفتره همم تبدا هذه المناوشات
همم البعض منها يطيح همم باصابات او تجر
عنه اصابات والبعض الاخر يمر بسلام ولكن
هذه المره كانت تصريحات وزير الدفاع
الهندي مباشره وصريحه وقال بان الصين
تحاول تغيير الوضع القائم بشكل احادي الى
اي مدى هذا الدقيق
لا اعتقدوا هذا لان
حسب هنا
التقارير
الجيش تحرير الشعب السوريين يقام بدوريات
بشكل
طبيعي
وتعرض للاعتراضات من الجيش الهندي وثم
اندلعت الاشتباك
هناك كثيره
في عام 2020
حتى في همم قبل 50 سنه يعني في همم
19 الحرب
ايضا نشنتها الهند على الصين وثم الصين
انتصرت ثم انسحبت على همم من الاعراض التي
كان انتصر عليه
ولكن همم كانت نعم
الطلاب
من همم
هل هي مجرد منى
تعتقد ام ان هناك تغيرات في الافق كما
يقول وزير الدفاع الهندي وبان الصين تعمل
على تحديد واقعه شديد
فيزيك الاسكان
على الحدود
بين فتره اخرى لكن لم تكن هناك مواجهات
فعليه حقيقيه منذ 50 عاما واول واحده منها
كانت قد حدثت في العام
2020 في شهر هذه المره الثانيه التي نشدوا
فيها منى
المشكله
عن ثلاث الاف كيلو متر يعاني من رسم حدود
سيء رسم صوره مغلوطه عن المنطقه الحدوديه
والهند والصينحتاح احتفاظات بالوضع الراهن
منذ عام
1962 بحيث ان الصين تقول ان هذه هي
منطقتنا والصين تقوله بالمقابل تلك هي
منطقه تونس وهذا التفاهم الذي تم لكن
مؤخرا هذا التفاهم همم قد اصابه خلل بعد
الحادث التي وقعت في العام 2020 وكان هناك
التوتر الذي تزايد تدريجيا والهن تقول ان
الصين كانت قد حصلت على جمله من المناطق
التي كانت الهند تقوم بتسيير دوريات فيها
ونحن وكانت الصين تدعي باننا همم نقوم
بالهجوم او الاعتداء على المناطق الخاصه
بهم اما الطرف المقابل فيقول باننا نقوم
فقط نحافظ على الوضع الراهن ولا نقوم
بالاعتداء على المناطق لكن المفهوم العام
في الهند
هو ان الصين قامت بالاستيلاء على مجموعه
كبيره من الاراضي الهنديه التي كانت حسب
مفاهيم من العامه ذات طبيعه هنديه وبصوره
الرسميه الحكومه الهنديه حتى اللحظه
اقترب بان الحكومه الصينيه قامت بالسيطره
على الجزء من ارضها اذا
قال رئيس الوزراء
اعلم بان هناك ترجمه
معها احداها يتحدث عن همم ان الهند تاخذ
هذه الاشتباكات على محمل الجديه همم سيدنا
نادر وان كانت اشتباكات همم لم ترقى او
يقول البعض لم ترقى الى همم
التبادل همم العسكري او الاشتباك العسكري
بين الطرفين يتحدث على مجموعه ولكن همم
كذلك تتوقع ان يتطور الموضوع الهند تاخذ
هذه الاشكات على احمد الجزئيه ويبدا بان
هناك
محاوله لضبط الامور قبل فوات الاوان
في المناطق الحدوديه مع الهند وتعملوا
كذلك من الجنه هنديه العمل مع حسين للحفاظ
على السلام والاستقرار في المنطقه
اه ولكن اه سعيد نادر يقول البعض بانه صين
تجرب هي في مرحله محاوله فهم استعدادات
نيودلهي في هذا الاطار هل يمكن ان يكون
الاتجاه هكذا بان الصين تحاول ان تتحرش
بنودلهي وتفرض امرا واقعا فيما بعد
التحركات الصينيه وكلها هو ردا على تحركات
الهنديه ولا يوجد اي مبادره
الى فاعل او تغيير اي شيء فيما يتعلق
بالمناطق الحوض حدوديه
هند ياخذ همم بجديه هذه التصريحات وهذه
التحركات والمناوشات هل يمكن حديث على
البدء بالتفكير بعسكره الحضور تعتقد
ميت
في هذه المناطق المتنازله عليها
وحلها حال المناطق اخرى مثل
التي لم تكن تحتوي او يا امها اي جنود اما
الان فبالتها هناك اعداد من العسكر الذين
يقومون
بتامين المنطقه طوال السنه وهناك بناء
لابونا تحتيه وطرق يتم شقها وكذلك الامر
بالنسبه لطرف المقابل الصيني
لدرجه ترقى الى حرب ونحن والناس كلنا ندرك
ما هي تداعيات الحرب
كل منها
لتصبحان القوه اقتصاديه داتا سياده
تتفهماني تبيعاتي وويلات الحرب لكنني ارى
بان التوتر
قد اثر وبدا
يطالب الهند بطرق متعدده لاننا لدينا حدود
مفتوحه مع الصين وهناك حدود مفتوحه من
الجهه الاخرى مع باكستان ويتوجب على الهند
ان تنفق اموالا طائله على ميزانتها
الدفاعيه في وقت لا يعيش فيه الاقتصاد
الهندي في افضل اوقاته كما كنا نرغبوا ذلك
اقتصاديه كبيره تفرض على الهند في بنائه
قلت بانه يمكن ان تفلت الامور ونجد نفسنا
في اطار حرب لا يتمنها احد يعني حرب بين
شعبين يمثل عدد سكانهما معا فول السكان
العالم فهذا سيكون همم له تداعيات على
العالم همم سيدنا نادر هل تعتقد بانه اين
فلاد قادر ان يشعل الفتيل حرب حقيقيه
يمكن ان
تتحولوا الى الحرب المفتوحه لان
كما اا
كما قلته تريد الحفاظ على السلام
وكذلك همم هناك همم همم اكثر من همم يعني
همم
السبعه عشره
المحادثات همم سته عشر بس همم المحادثات
بين القاده الجيش اي شيء ف- همم اعتقدوا
هناك همم هناك اليه لاداره هذه الخلافات
شكرا لكم